hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to in Lucy's eyes now
we are headed to the library and I don't
know why oh it must have been a
two-floor library because this is a lady
address lady and dress and who walks why
do we have so many boxes we know they
bring in ladies in dresses wait so do I
need to worry about Lucy or do I need to
worry about the reincarnated version of
my why the ghosts tegu that was my wife
who misses me so much I know there's
gotta be who this door is new I can't
even open it it's so new flashback let's
start this session with you telling me
what you're experiencing Richard please
call me dick ever since the tragic death
of my wife things haven't been the same
sometimes I still feel her presence in
these halls it's like she's not really
gone I see the mind often does not
accept the loss of a loved one
until the soul has had its time to heal
may I ask you how she died she was
rarely happy in the end something was
troubling her she wanted a family wanted
a child but we couldn't take that step I
didn't have the time she took her own
life after an argument we had
oh that's where you gonna end it oh
that's lovely that's a great story
that's definitely the beginning of all
great stories
you couldn't have time your name really
is dick oh here we go again I'm feeling
it
do you have any reason to feel guilt in
somewhere ah because I'm a douche Oh
I was always reasonable during our
arguments stayed calm the entire time
I understand
how often do you see your wife I can see
her now she's standing right behind you
really is she looking at us she's
looking straight at David
I'm so sorry David something now gonna
go good for you sorry Paul psychiatrist
David Vic's wife got to him bad okay so
I'm exploring around I imagine I might
get another flashback but that seemed
kind of the end of that little string
there god this is so bizarre and
interesting and it looks so cheerful is
that my wife all right my first instinct
was to go smash that pot well I thought
against it that would be a terribly
irresponsible thing to do it also wasn't
it just dark and stormy before I could
have sworn that I was scared out of my
mind at a dark and stormy castle now
it's a happy fun castle what whoa whoa
okay okay oh it's a dark and stormy
again oh that you hey how did it
hi okay bye bye-bye okay oh no oh no oh
oh oh hi
[ __ ] - goddamn alright cool
I didn't want to go that way anyway just
want to say hi to my wife oh I think
we're done for today
good I was wondering if I could have
your permission to enter the archives I
haven't explored much of the castle and
I was particularly interested in looking
through some old documents about this
great Citadel as I haven't found a whole
lot of information about it in the
library
yeah I'm afraid the archives are
off-limits for at least a month where
makes Explorer one of those visitors was
murdered in the study area by an
uninvited man his psychotic behavior
ever since has been worrying but have no
worries I can assure you that the
criminal has been
dealt with oh yes I see but can you not
make an exception even if I wanted to it
would be impossible at this point the
archives are filled with workers as it's
currently under renovation
it's the largest victim of the unusual
storms that have been disassembling
these walls ever since the death of my
is it a smear is advised you go back to
your quarters and rest David yes David
sure this session was just as demanding
for you as it was for me oh yeah is it
this mirror is dick sounding a little
more sinister than usual oh and I can go
in the oh this way my Lucy oh no what is
happening why why is this all a thing Oh
horrible and I love it
oh man I'm so jazzed that I found a good
amnesia custom story cuz goddamn this
one is gonna be good its pacing itself
perfectly it's starting nice and slow
but getting some truly like like good
jolts out of me and setting up the pace
for something terrifying like it's got
all the good ingredients and this looks
exactly like Castle Brennan back from
the first amnesia days where things look
a little bit samey fool what oh it's a
flicker light okay oh good oh hey hey
hey what are you doing
sorry okay
why oh no my painting of me oh my eyes
kind of wet a little wonky all right
then oh okay all right cool I like this
this is my favorite I'm a big fan of
this stop that don't much care for see
subtlety is the key of everything in
horror subtlety but knowing when to
press your hand like just because
something as subtle doesn't mean it has
to be so settled it oh hey oh oh oh oh I
didn't notice you there at first I just
saw a claw
oh you're beckoning towards me what is
that dead rats hey how's it going well
this was easy to find these puzzles sure
are straightforward see the like like
there it's a hard balance to strike Oh
cuz they're like a not a gent oh no I
got a LK it's a hard balance to strike
because you want to start out settling
this is like a really good example of it
because you're starting
okay oh now I'm trapped down here with
it okay why did I do this
oh why do I do this why did I do this
voluntarily okay what happened
oh it's getting quite blurry okay I'll
just get out of here now good me happy
fun day shut up and turn around even
though I exactly just did turn around
shut up everybody out there I just
wanted to make sure those done by me I
knew there wasn't my I just had to make
sure I had to make sure how to make sure
how to make sure I had to make sure okay
how to make sure how to make sure make
sure that make sure okay cool key I love
keys Norma catism number one that's my
favorite key after the last incident in
the steady air the berry orders to build
one new door lock mechanism
okay okay I read a note in the middle of
a door opening excuse me I'll be right
with you it's brand-new lunch time from
London high security level doors
controlled by steam-powered engine with
two cores steam and one each core is
released by a key safety locks blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah okay
I'll consult this later when I get to
that thing but right now I'm concerned
about not dying kind of my primary thing
right now why do I keep following the
doors and automatically open and just
like drawn to them that's my crazy gamer
instinct I'm just too good at games it's
problem the problem okay so this one so
that's all gobbed up the new mechanical
doors shut there should be a way to get
through okay
all right so what I need to do is it
okay alright okay okay okay why do I
keep doing this why do I keep doing this
hello why do I keep doing this why do I
keep going in rooms that I know my
lovely wife is leading me towards this
is gonna end in my death hi okay thank
you tickly rope don't mind me making my
way downtown walking fast
we wouldn't passing him homebound
okay oh it's not tiny by stem you're not
like them
back there in here know what anyone
anyway cookie why is that where the
locks go okay so there we go gone um one
bingo Bongo for number two
Pookie that hurt me a lot I'm glad her
bit of it over there bit of our god I
gotta get a come on whoa whoa did it it
did okay cool that only hurt a lot my
face is entirely sculpt off but I'm good
right okay good I can meet my doom at
the hands of a lovely wife while looking
for my probably haunted daughter
wait did my wife say that we didn't want
a family why do I even have a daughter
then who's Lucy who's Lucy stop it
please I don't much care for any of this
not good stuff okay oh yeah yeah or no
no I want to go home unless this is my
home
Wow blood well how did I let my home get
to this point why did I want to come
back why was I staying here in the first
place who lit this candle
why is everything everything I don't
think there's gonna be anything in here
besides more uh more matchbox nothing
thing over there
what was that were you what do you want
me to do okay I understand you're
talking gibberish and I shouldn't
understand you very reason to be in here
no okay good all right stop it I don't
want to go in there unless you're trying
to keep me out of something and I need
to go in there okay
huh okay okay all right okay all right
okay this game knows how to keep you on
edge that's for damn sure I don't know
if you guys are getting the same
experience out of it that I am
put ha damn ha ha ha oh now it's open oh
good
who's blocking the doorway login ok ok
ok ok ok
oh why did I like this it was right here
oh god the basement down the stairs my
darling oh good this is where I need all
the matches probably oh good Oh
what horrors weighed me down here or
maybe it will be a happy fun basement
maybe it's gonna be like a finished
basement that's a rumpus room
I love rumpus rooms hi oh this your
friends okay it's all a party down here
right oh oh
cats up those eyes for a second there I
know through the eyes have bad news
bears okay fine why is it cracked up it
slightly yeah I don't trust you haunted
rug get out here haunted broom
what is that exactly I think I need to
worry about I don't know what they're
thinking what's out of thing I don't
know I don't know I don't know is the
thing Oh should I try to move all this
out of the way probably let me just make
a whole bunch of noise excuse me
Oh pound it's gonna take a while yeah
okay I can't get this hope help that
music sounds fun
I can't wait to wait for what's gonna
come out of that music but first I want
to open here and get the hell out of
here
and live my life and not die that's so
much task okay
oh good okay that's where I would unlock
this probably good because I need a way
out of here or maybe someone was trying
to stop people from getting in for some
reason okay
this rumpus remain as fun as I thought
it would be cause a good sense
all right I'm not gonna go towards the
FACA death thank you very much
I'm not gonna go down there I don't care
how many my darlings you tell me I ain't
going down there cuz I'm all out of time
for this part so thank you everybody so
much for watching get ready for more in
Lucy's eyes coming at you very soon I
will get to it I'm not okay but either
way I'll go down in the basement in the
next episode I'm sure it'll be fun and
fantastic let me know what you think of
this video or let me know what you think
of this whole game in the comments below
I'd love to hear your input on is I love
it on I really like it at the same time
really ate it so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next
face-first into it
Oh